ready to revolutionize your garden with
perennial vegetables forget the hassle
of replanting every year and enjoy
plants that return Season after
season start with asparagus plant it
once and it rewards you with Bountiful
Spears for years Sun chokes bring a
Nutty twist to your meals while the
ground nut gives you both tubers and
beans artichokes with their cactus-like
look produce more each year rhubarb adds
color and flavor to desserts but
remember its leaves are toxic
horseradish is a spicy perennial that
grows fast and strong while redico
thrives in cool Seasons with its Tangy
bite bunching onions are perfect for
your kitchen and Sorel with its lemony
Zing is super easy to grow transform
your garden into a perennial paradise
and enjoy effortless long lasting
harvests